and finally new rule you shouldn't be
able to talk about Dei anymore in
America Dei that's diversity equity and
inclusion without including atheists
[Applause]
thank you a few of you
as we're approaching a third of the
population now I shouldn't have to beg
for this for God's sake
it's outrageous there are this many of
us and there are still zero reputation
representation in government Congress
has 535 members and only a handful of
even sheepishly admit their religiously
unaffiliated the Supreme Court is two
Protestants one Jew and six people more
Catholic than the Pope
[Laughter]
and even intellectual presidents like
Obama who admit to being secular
humanists
have to pretend to be religious no one
has been able to admit their shameful
secret I don't believe in ghosts
next Sunday is Easter so enjoy
first you've heard of it okay yeah enjoy
if that's your thing bunny rabbits that
eggs to celebrate the Son of God
whatever floats your Ark
but it's not fair that people who belong
to one of the big religions they get
they all get this Cosmic personal day
where the world revolves around them I
mean here we are in the middle of the
great egg shortage and yet next Sunday
we're going to take the few eggs we have
and hide them in the yard
thank you
there's also now a movement for schools
to officially recognize Ramadan the
Muslim month of fasting and I'm all for
it or anything that gets our fat kids to
eat less
but while approximately three million
Americans celebrate Ramadan 100 million
say they have no religion at all what
the where's our day
it's not really so much to ask that this
many people get one day a year when we
recommit ourselves to observable reality
one day with no atonement no corpse
reanimation
no fasting no tray in your house no
big rock to Circle no dirt on your
forehead no candles to light and please
God no fruitcakes
just a yearly three-day weekend to
celebrate your deeply held belief that
with Monday off you can drink on Sunday
night
and get to sleep in because there is no
place to gather
to affirm we all believe the same
we we know what we believe and what we
don't believe we don't need to rub
elbows with other people who don't
believe it too and we don't need to
commercialize our holiday like all the
other religions do atheist day is about
not buying something
like virgin birth I'm not buying it
we have the numbers we can do this
fastest growing religious group in the
United States are nuns no not the kind
who used to beat you with a ruler for
being left-handed
I mean people who when asked how much
they want to be involved with a religion
say none
the unaffiliated share of the population
consisting of people who describe their
religious identity as atheist agnostic
or nothing in particular has risen from
five percent in 1972 to 15 percent in
2005 to 32 percent today you're welcome
[Applause]
unless you think it's only young
educated white liberals no just about
everybody is losing their religion or as
I call it holy ghosting
the average age of a nun is 43 a third
are people of color a quarter voted for
Trump 70 percent don't have a four-year
college degree Millennials are the first
generation that are less than a majority
Christian their idea of hell is a coffee
shop with no Wi-Fi
when asked how often they go to church
34 percent of younger Millennials
answered seldom slash never or don't
know
foreign
don't know hey kids going to church is
like having an orgasm if you didn't know
you did you didn't
[Applause]
and that's another great thing about
atheist day you don't have to fake it
you don't even have to be an atheist to
enjoy it just like you don't have to be
Christian to enjoy Christmas I still
love Christmas you don't have to be an
atheist to celebrate atheist day I'd
like it to be the one day a year that
the devout can get a little taste of
what it's like to live your life without
some mythical daddy figure judging and
condemning you for being the exact
person he made you
oh
atheist day should be a day for
believers to stop and ask yourselves why
why
make up a being who's constantly
disappointed in you
you don't need it you've got your wife
[Applause]
and your parents your siblings your
co-workers your trainer when you don't
give a hundred and ten percent
there are plenty of people right here on
Earth who will gladly make you feel like
a lame incompetent up
why make up one more it's like adding an
extra mother-in-law
why Always Be tormented I better not
make Jesus Cry Baby Jesus cry why is he
sitting behind you on a plane
wouldn't you like one day one goddamn
Day in the year when for 24 hours you
can tell your God to climb down off your
ass because trying to please a man who's
not there set you up for a lifetime of
misery just ask Tiffany Trump